diesen hawking ist widerlegt wo
jahrzehnte arbeitete er an einer theorie
die den urknall umgehen sollte das
universum ohne rand jetzt mathematiker
vom max planck institut für
gravitationsphysik in potsdam und vom
perimeter institute in kanada seine
theorie mit neuen mathematischen
methoden durchgerechnet und widerlegt
warum sich die hawking gehört habe was
für die physik bedeutet jetzt winkel zum
2 1 zum fixen herzlich willkommen
es ist das größte rätsel der physik und
auch der menschheit woher kommen wir
wie entstand das alles gab es einen
urknall und hatte gott seine finger im
spiel
der urknall ist für die physik ein
wirklich ziemlich unangenehmes ereignis
denn in diesem moment wenn alles und
damit ist wirklich alles gemeint an
einem punkt verein zwar versackten für
sich ihre gesetze geld nicht und das ist
natürlich unwissenschaftlich jedenfalls
also die wissenschaft hat keinen zugriff
auf diesen moment die walking hatte eine
lösung für dieses problem doch es war
sehr theoretisch und konnte nie bewiesen
oder widerlegt werden
es hätte den urknall vermieden dabei war
hawking derjenige der in seiner ersten
wissenschaftlichen arbeit die bis dahin
geltende theorie des free state
universums also eines universums in
einem dauerhaften stabilen zustand
widerlegte und sogar seinen doktorvater
dennis gejammer davon überzeugt wird
später weiß er dann die
unvermeidlichkeit einer singularität am
anfang des universums nach also dem
urknall bis hierhin und nicht weiter
dass eckigen kirche gerne gehabt der
jesuitenorden lud ihn deshalb 981 zu
einer kosmologie konferenz ein und papst
johannes paul der zweite die kniete ihn
hier nicht weiter zu forschen und diese
singularität der kirche und damit gott
zu überlassen
wie sollte von der wissenschaft nicht
angetastet werden also diese
singularität der papst kniete damals
wirklich vororte nieder
das schien ihn aber eher zu ermuntern
und so veröffentlichte der verein ja
später die theorie vom universum ohne
grenzen die auf der erdkugel gab es in
dieser theorie kein ende und keinen
anfang hinter dem südpol ist nicht das
ende der welt es geht einfach weiter
zahlreiche probleme werden damit gelöst
es gebe keine singularitäten an denen
die naturgesetze ihre gültigkeit
einbüßten und keinen raum zeit rand an
dem man sich auf gott oder irgendein
neues gesetz berufen müsste um die
grenze bedingungen der raumzeit
festzulegen man könnte einfach sagen die
grenzen des universums ist sagt es keine
grenze hat das universum
wäre völlig in sich abgeschlossen und
keinerlei äußeren einflüssen unterworfen
es wäre wieder erschaffen noch zerstörer
es würde einfach sein loslegten hawking
das wäre die lösung für die physik
gewesen
hätte am anfang des universums gegolten
doch jetzt haben jean-luc lenas vom max
planck institut für gravitationsphysik
dem albert einstein institut und seine
kollegen jobs feldbrügge und neil turok
vom perimeter institute in kanada diese
theorie mit neuen mathematischen
methoden durchgerechnet im wind zu einem
im wahrsten sinne des wortes umwerfenden
ergebnis gekommen diesen hawking hat
sich geirrt barocken theorie wäre das
universum als quantenfluktuationen aus
dem nichts entstanden
damit wäre es am anfangstage grund
gewesen aber viel weniger als bei einer
singularität die physik hätte so auch am
anfang des universums funktioniert das
große problem der menschheit wäre damit
gelöst gewesen
die forscher rechneten jetzt aber die
konsequenzen dieser theorie aus demnach
wären aus dieser quantenfluktuationen
zahlreiche universen entstanden und die
wären auch noch sehr unregelmäßig und
eben nicht regelmäßig wie unser
universum geworden und sogar die meisten
entstanden universen wären unregelmäßig
gewesen unser universum wäre so erst gar
nicht entstanden waren zahlreiche kleine
instabile die nach ihrem entstehen
sofort wieder zusammen gestürzt werden
stephen hawkings theorie ist also
widerlegt labem ob jetzt etwas ähnliches
passiert ist und die
quantenfluktuationen tvi in schach
gehalten worden ist das wollen die
forscher jetzt als nächstes durchrechnen
oder es bleibt erst mal doch beim
urknall so wie wir ihn kennen und bei
den forschungen in dieser richtung gibt
es neue erkenntnisse wir werden es sehen
und zwar hier bei pixum feind entwickeln
männer die videos nicht verpassen wollte
ich mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke ja
und hier geht es weiter mit sieben
hawking schmeißt alles um es gibt keine
schwarzen löcher wer spannendes thema
einfach draufklicken und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt